la crise entre alger et paris va-t-elle
affecter le cours de l'opération barkan
dimanche 3 octobre le pays a interdit le
survol de son espace aérien aux avions
militaires de l'opération barkan
l'impact est jusqu'ici limité puisque
seuls deux vols logistiques ont été
concernés la plupart des avions français
accédant à la bande sahélo-saharienne
n'ont pas besoin de survoler le
territoire algérien il décore la
majorité de niamey au niger mais ce
raidissement de l'algérie fait augurer
d'autres blocages durant le déroulement
de la fin de l'opération barkan
l'interdiction de survol n'a pas été
rendue officielle
le porte parole de l'état major des
armées parce qu'elle n'y a ni à
minimiser son impact mais le
refroidissement des relations
diplomatiques entre paris et alger est
notable les propos d' emmanuel macron
répercutée par le journal le monde où
provoqué l'ire du président algérien
abdel madjid tebboune lors d'une
conversation avec deux jeunes français
d'origine algérienne le locataire de
l'elysée avait évoqué une rente
mémorielle entretenu par l'algérie une
histoire officielle totalement réécrite
par cette ancienne colonie un discours
qui repose sur une haine de la france la
présidence algérienne a émis un
communiqué notifiant que les
déclarations du président français
emmanuel macron à son encontre
représentait une atteinte inacceptable à
la mémoire de plus de 5 millions de
résistants tués par la france coloniale
en outre paris compte aussi réduire le
nombre de visas accordés aux algériens
ou marocains à hauteur de 50 % et dans
une moindre mesure aux tunisiens
l'algérie vient donc de rappeler son
ambassadeur mohamed antar daoud des
relations qui souffle le chaud et le
froid les deux pays oscillant entre
réconciliation et querelles en 2020 un
rapport sur l'occupation de l'algérie a
été rendu dans le but d'apaiser les
tensions le document élaboré par
l'historien benjamin stora né en algérie
avant l'indépendance exclus et des
excuses de paris l'algérie avait fustigé
un travail nos objectifs reprochant
l'absence de reconnaissance officielle
par la france des crimes de guerre et
contre l'humanité perpétrés pendant les
cent trente années de l'occupation de
l'algérie depuis le torchon continue de
brûler sur cette base comment espérer
une collaboration optimale entre alger
et paris à l'heure du désengagement
progressif de barkan pourtant l'algérie
est un allié de poids trop evènement les
forces françaises doivent migrer des
bases malienne vers le sud malien et le
niger l'algérie s'est toujours placé en
tant que médiatrice du dialogue inter
malien mais ces derniers mois l'algérie
a semblé vouloir se positionner comme un
acteur clé du sahel avec la visite au
mali en août du ministre algérien des
affaires étrangères ramtane lamamra il
avait participé à une réunion de
médiation internationale dans la crise
malienne et avait annoncé son intention
d'aider l'armée malienne à s'étoffer et
se structurer la france souhaite par
ailleurs alléger son dispositif barkan
au profit des forces européennes takouba
alors que le dispositif sera plus léger
moins interventionniste les brouilles
diplomatiques avec l'algérie risque
d'encore d'entraver sa fluidité la
france devrait pouvoir s'appuyer sur
l'algérie pour négocier ce virage et le
grand départ ce n'est que le dernier
avatar d'une opération militaire
contestée est enlisée qui doit s'achever
au premier trimestre 2002